oh hi Internet welcome back to another
exciting episode of game life on today's
episode we're going to talk to two of
the men without whom the video game
industry might not exist today Ralph
Baer the inventor of the first home
video game console the magnavox odyssey
and al al khor in the designer of pong
the game that ignited the arcade
industry and then later everybody's
favorite Wired magazine senior editor
Chris Baker is going to be back and
we're going to talk about god of war
chains of olympus for the PSP as soon as
his battery finishes charging am i right
well I'm Ralph Baer I'm the guy who
committed the original sin creating
first video game parents keep coming to
me and accusing me of creating those
horrible games of course when I
explained to them that I didn't really
do the games when I came up with with a
concept of video games and then built
original machines eyes glaze over
because concepts are not something that
anybody understands when i work till
around building a television set we used
to test equipment that put patterns on
the screen and in order to be able to
adjust the television said for linear
diff i hide for with that's the only
thing and i gave me the idea of doing
something with a said he was a test
equipment I allowed you to do something
on the screen and that's a good idea
germinated but I didn't really act on it
until a good what from early 50s to mid
sixteen fifty years later we
demonstrated to RCA motorola Sylvania
three or four others magnavox and they
all came to all set that's great stuff
but nobody moved off a dime and one of
the me pisa at RCA left became a VP for
marketing at magnavox in a New York
office sales office he was so impressed
by what he saw he said it's a go just
like that one guy with visual pong was
an exercise and in getting used to doing
video games because they just got said
only one of their video game before so
it was the simplest game nor can think
of but he motivated me to try to do a
really good job at it not just goof off
so he lied to me and told me that he had
a contract from General Electric to for
a home consumer game that's really going
to be tough and the fact that nobody
from GE ever called or came by or phoned
or any worse a letter didn't occur to me
you know this was not true and and once
I had it done and I added things to make
the play better I was kind of depressed
because it was too expensive for a home
game but it played pretty good so he put
it the box and put it on the
tation and worked the first location for
pong was at Andy Capps tavern so I came
down to check it out and I discovered
that the cash box was so full of
quarters he'd just overflowed and opened
it up so I filled my pockets full of
quarters gave in my business card and
said gee the next time that happens just
give me a call i can do this so i had a
couple hundred bucks with the quarters
in my pocket made it in the week if you
had to go back if you had all that
technology at your disposal when you
first made it but could make any change
to the original design would you know
anything like i'm too lazy once he at
the door it's done fine i want to see it
again and we're back and as you can see
I've got wired magazine's Chris Baker
here with me and we are going to talk
about god of war chains of olympus for
the PSP chains of olympus is one of the
best looking PSP games today and it
really captures the look and feel of its
console brethren the ancient Greek
monsters and the the columns and the
ruins everything about it looks great
yeah seriously I wouldn't want to live
in ancient Greece because you just
getting attacked by minotaurs like I'm
just on a constant basis and god of war
PSP does bring that same feel certainly
what they've absolutely nailed are the
controls that's always been an issue
with the PSP because it's got one less
stick to move but you almost never think
about the controls as you're playing as
you're tearing heads off and ripping
people in half and blood is flying you
completely forget that you're playing a
handheld game it feels just like the
you'll playstation 2 god of wars there
there is definitely a bit of a learning
curve because you don't have the right
analog stick anymore which which used a
dodge and so used to just be able to
sort of hit that and dodge out of the
way of enemy attacks you can't do that
anymore because there is no right analog
stick on the PSP so we have to do is
hold down the L&R shoulder buttons and
then to the left analog stick and again
it eventually it clicks but um it does
take a little bit of getting used to
from moment to moment though it really
looks terrific the animations are spot
on some of the effects with smoke and
blood flying just beautiful there's no
filler in this game you move directly
you know from from story beat to action
to story B you know nothing ever drags
you down there's no backtracking there's
no staying in a level for too long it
really just addicts you and keeps you
moving and that actually kind of works
against god of war PSP in the other the
console games were nine to ten hours
long god of war for PSP you can pretty
much rip through it in upton five to six
hours yeah it's a it's a terrific five
or six hours except at the end it starts
getting a little bit repetitive but it's
definitely you know I I would prefer a
shorter game where there's less
monotonous fetch quests and repeating
stone it's it's still a great game you
just might want to rent it instead of
buying it god of war chains of olympus
is getting pretty high ratings all over
the place and i think honestly it's
getting a little bit overrated yes it's
it's sort of like when grand theft auto
liberty City Stories came out for PSP
there's an initial euphoria that they
they managed to squeeze all of this
great stuff that was in the console game
the hand
version but once the euphoria wears off
you're left with what's still a great
game but it's not quite up to the
earlier entries in the series right and
again I think what's really important is
to say that is still a great game it's
probably one of the best games on the
PSP maybe the best action adventure game
on the PSP but you know it's it's only
five six hours long it's a lot less
scope than the than the the console big
brothers uh and and for that reason I'm
going to stick with the rating of an
eight out of ten that sounds fair